mais d'abord on revient sur cette
intervention policière qui a tourné au
drame ce week-end dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi un équipage de police
secours du commissariat de Tours à prise
en chasse un véhicule qui venait de
griller un feu rouge et qui circulait à
vive allure au lieu de s'arrêter le
conducteur a pris la fuite dans le
quartier des rives du Cher et c'est là
qu'il a trouvé la mort elle est
précisions de Florent Clavel
il s'appelait Yassine Mustapha il avait
35 ans quelques fleurs et un portrait de
la victime sont visibles ici en bord de
chair c'est en effet à cet endroit que
le corps inanimé de la victime a été
remonté par les pompiers après plus
d'une demi-heure de recherche dans l'eau
72 heures après l'effet le scénario
fatal est encore incertain et les
raisons d'une telle prise de risque par
la victime aussi pourquoi a-t-il voulu
échapper aux policiers au point de se
jeter dans la rivière qui plus est
l'homme n'était connu des services de
police que pour des délits mineurs c'est
pas une personne qui était un délinquant
d'habitude c'est une personne qui avait
été condamnée à deux reprises à des
peines d'amendes pour des faits liés au
contentieux de la route on ne sait pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a pris la fuite je
l'ignore des analyses toxicologiques
vont être pratiqués dans les prochaines
semaines pour déterminer s'il était
éventuellement sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants ou d'alcool et tout ça nous
permettra de nous donner quelques
éléments de réponse sur le déroulement
plus exact de ces faits les premiers
éléments de l'enquête ont été
communiqués par le pro de la République
quelques heures à peine après les faits
3h20 ce samedi matin un conducteur
roulant à vive allure grille un feu
rouge sous les yeux de quatre policiers
en service à l'approche de leur voiture
gyrophare et sirène allumée l'homme
refuse de s'arrêter nous sommes alors
dans le quartier des rives du Cher sa
voiture vient percuter un arbre quelques
instants après l'homme sort alors
poursuivi par les policiers échappent à
un tir de Taser avant de se jeter dans
le Cher là le scénario est plus flou la
victime ne savait-elle pas nager
a-t-elle fait un malaise toujours est-il
qu'un policier tente de le secourir sans
y parvenir le procureur de la République
de Tours a ouvert deux enquêtes l'une
menées par l'IGPN la police des polices
l'autre par la police judiciaire
nous ce qu'on veut faire c'est toute la
lumière sur cette histoire et donner à
la famille de l'auteur de ce refus
d'obtempérer
toutes les pièces de procédure qui lui
permettront de comprendre à un moment
donné ce qui s'est passé et donc pour
faire toute la lumière il faut bien
entendu faire deux enquêtes et ses deux
enquêtes elles sont sous le saut de
l'impartialité menées par deux services
d'enquêtes différents l'autopsie du
corps de la victime avait lieu
aujourd'hui les résultats seront connus
prochainement ils devraient permettre
d'en savoir plus sur les circonstances
exactes de son décès